android 21 lab coat was one of the most
broken characters in fighting game
history bro yo what
that damage is insane
sorry what the
yeah
her kit was completely unbalanced but
one ability in particular was so
overpowered that it almost
single-handedly killed the game
there you go
that is so cheap it reduces damage by 21
which obviously the damage output in the
game is already low enough i don't know
what band i was thinking
from casual to the pro level lab coat 21
was an unavoidable terror who forced
everyone to play her i know
my chat does not like watching it you
know it's not that fun to watch and the
one question on everyone's mind was
why why would the devs release a
character so obviously broken and then
go completely silent were they really
trying to ruin their own game no okay
it's gonna hit me there's nothing i can
do anyway at this point there's just
nothing i can do about it i was gonna
say once you get hit i mean really you
don't get that i really just like that
you can do it in a combo
hey folks before we get into the video i
want to ask you to please sub to the
channel and turn on notifications if you
haven't done it yet it really really
helps and once you've done that please
head over to twitch.tv for esports and
throw us a follow we are going live all
the time we just did our evo co-stream
you're watching this a month later but i
did it yesterday which is why my voice
is gone we are going live with all kinds
of amazing content like that all the
time over on twitch you don't want to
miss us so again please follow us okay
so it's kind of impossible to explain
just how busted lab coat 21 was when she
came out in february 2022 it really
seemed like the dragon ball fighters dev
team set out to make the most broken
character they possibly could see when
most people think about a good fighting
game they're looking for cool characters
a great battle system and lots and lots
of post launch content but plenty of
fighting games have great support in
core design if you don't have at least
that your game is going to be a flop
these days what actually makes your game
stand out from the competition is good
balance and a lab coat 21 spat in the
face of good balance
this character
yes and no because bandai or whoever
arxes did not learn their lesson with
balancing this game they just gave
another character and medium starter ex
lariat that goes through everything
which means
they don't see the problem which means
this meta is gonna suck
for a lot longer every game has a
shorthand of key tools you want a
character to have if you want them to be
strong and when it comes to dragon ball
fighters
lab coat 21 had all of them for example
quick low hitting attacks have been
strong in fighters since day one and a
lab coat had six of them on top of that
she also had a beam insane pressure an
otg that was stupidly easy to combo into
a meterless 4-frame reversal and an
anterior that could hit on all sides lab
coat 21 is a stupid dumb broken
character right i don't think anyone
i don't think anyone will remotely
disagree with this all of those crazy
abilities put together made her the
strongest character in the game by far
but incredibly
none of them were the actual problem no
the real issue was her level 1 super
photon pulse photon pulse was a command
grab that did
2121 damage get it 2121 but more
importantly opponents hit with the grab
received a 21 debuff to their damage
well labcoat 21 got a 21
buff to all of her specials damage the
fact that it's permanent is the big
problem right because if it was not
permanent or if like it went away when
she tags out or something like that i
don't think it would even be an issue
and if you think that's overpowered
it gets worse unlike some other command
grabs lab labco21's photon pulse didn't
have a telegraphed startup animation
making it really hard to react to when
used raw but the thing is she didn't
have to use it wrong because unlike most
command grabs she could combo into it
making it an easy enough tool for even
low skilled players to abuse any touch
led to a photon pulse meaning any
character lab coat hit was effectively
useless and she could give the debuff to
each character on the enemy team even if
you know nothing about fighting games
it's not hard to grasp how broken this
is a 21 damage debuff to one side while
the other side gets a 21 damage buff is
incomprehensible for context sparking
fighter's main comeback mechanic is a
once per game temporary buff that gives
your active character 21
bonus damage for 7 to 21 seconds for one
bar lab code could completely nullify
that with their 21 damage debuff meaning
sparking just turn your character back
into their normal self again just
imagine how bad it was without sparking
labcoat was so good that on the wiki she
was listed as having literally zero cons
so she's got a lot of unique tools the
debuff being one of them buffing up
herself all for one bar it's invincible
she can otg you she's got the best beam
in the game she can jail you from almost
any situation she's got insane specials
like just everything about character she
can heal herself like she's got just way
too many powerful things and of course
like with any top one super broken
character everyone had to pick up and
learn her which led to even more
problems everybody playing lab coat made
the game incredibly boring to watch no
one wanted to get touched in command
grab so neutral became extremely slow as
players poked each other from a screen
away remember labcoat's pressure was
also insane so even if you blocked her
you have to pop sparking just to end the
block string and reset right back to
super slow neutral on top of that you
were basically trolling if you didn't
pick her so at the pro level it was all
lab coat mirror matches the matches
could take extremely long because your
opponent might have
lab coat 21 you have lab coat 21 you're
nerfing each other's
damage and the matches just take forever
and it's really boring to watch as well
but mirror matches between top 1
characters aren't exactly new for
fighters the game has struggled with
balance issues since basically day one
early on dbfz wasn't exactly broken but
a few characters were just categorically
better than the rest if you wanted to
succeed you needed characters like cell
kid boo or android 16 on your team dolph
got the man out he's got solo vegeta
here rocky
big bang attack punish
uh
five bars
five bars on the side of the kids sonic
fox mistake from goichi is gonna cost
him so much life
the ghost bring in that level three
let's see i'm like
them potentially one picks up away
ladies and gentlemen from taking this
away
sonic fox your combo breaker 2018 dragon
ball fighters champion but in those
early days people were still
experimenting to find out what worked
and what the best teams could look like
fighters was new and exciting and to a
certain degree it felt like anything
could happen with any team
oh what a challenge why did he block
that he dashed forward
watch it
oh my god
completely
another round of existence we don't
break into dragon rushing this is crazy
that goichi is that poised right now so
is leftman they are so calm right now
with only 30 seconds on the on the timer
he's
but those days didn't last long once dlc
characters started dropping the meta
quickly reshaped itself around the ones
that were worth buying when bardock the
game's first dlc character dropped in
march just a month after the game came
out he quickly took over the scene and
it didn't stop there over the next three
years bandai namco dropped 20 dlc
characters some were arguably unplayable
but many totally warped the game and
things really came to a head with gt
goku
a lot of patience in the two oh sonic
he's gonna get the pickups yeah this is
big for fox and we've got also like full
balls able to get into the game
situation for the mix
one and two spirit bomb thank you
servant more energy sonic is one mix
away from resetting the brackets
for the dragon ball fighter saga and
sonic fox just blessed us with a bracket
reset gt goku had great damage he was
super fast he had an amazing beam he had
good pressure he had lots of lows and i
bet this is sounding pretty familiar at
this point he was so strong that at red
bull spain in 2019 13 players in the top
16 were running him the winner of almost
every single major event in 2019 used gt
goku the character was clearly a problem
and while he was finally nerfed in early
2020 he got replaced on many top players
teams with yet another broken fighter
ultra instinct goku can he defeat ui
goku
listen
you're out gt outbreak in long hair we
waited you i go through
defense acting
defense press the button we're not
season two no more this is season three
baby
okay
oh
and here we go
hazardoco keeps it alive like we said it
kind of felt like bandai namco wanted to
sell people busted characters break the
game nerf them and then repeat it all
over again so as dbfc grew the dlc cast
was getting as big as the launch roster
and every season there was at least one
character who threatened to upend the
game's balance the fighters community
adapted every time though and you could
argue that if the developer's goal was
to constantly shake up the meta and keep
the game interesting powerful characters
like gt goku gogeta blue ui goku and
super saiyan 4 gogeta were hugely
successful but lab coat 21 was different
the meta can't adapt to something that
broken and to make matters worse it
seemed like labcoat wasn't just the last
character the game would ever see but
also the last update entirely no more
balance patches just overpowered lab
coat forever
caught them oh wait this is huge
oh my god
so for a time lab coat ruined the game
because like i already said if you
weren't picking her you were basically
throwing money away it was so bad that
at combo breaker 2022 there were 33 lab
coats in top 48 and what's messed up is
that character diversity outside of lab
coat was actually some of the best it
had ever been but the fact that almost
every team featured her killed the
hyphen
for months fans cried for a nerf but
there was no response and nobody knew
what was going on did the devs just not
care about the game anymore was it some
sort of weird conspiracy theory to kill
the game now and get people hyped for a
sequel were they just trying to squeeze
more money out of a four-year-old title
i feel like it was probably a bit rushed
like i just feel like they didn't
consider how much it could affect
tournaments and the players and the
viewers eventually tournament organizers
took matters into their own hands
after months of banned discussions in
the community labcoat was banned at ceo
2022 and that wasn't even the first time
she got banned other tos and even pros
were stepping up to try to fix the game
by getting rid of her what's going on
bum here to let you guys know that lab
coat 21 will be banned tonight
for the city of mayhem 93 dbfz on the
ps4 uh reason being is because the super
is very toxic for the game it reduces
damage by 21 which obviously the damage
output in the game is already low enough
i don't know what bandai was thinking
so
you know since bandai is not going to do
anything about it i'm gonna do something
about it with lab coat out of the
picture at some events the meta evolved
obviously many teams still consisted of
these other top tier picks but at least
we got to see what tournaments looked
like without her and then
finally after months of outcry the devs
nerfed labco21 and she didn't just get
nerfed she got gutted less damage worse
combos slower attacks and of course she
lost the ability to combo into photon
pulse the command grab that broke the
game
labcoat debuff isn't really a thing
because you can pretty much only do it
if you're trying to do it as a reversal
or if you're doing it in a block string
because it doesn't combo you can't combo
into it anymore it now took real skill
to land the command grab which meant
that there was a risk associated with
trying to get the debuff but here's the
thing even without photon pulse lab coat
was still the best character in the game
by a mile and plenty of people thought
the nerfs didn't even come close to
changing that her toolset is still one
of the best in the whole game like she
still has insane damage she still has
crazy special moves um
yeah she's still got really good block
strings she's got lots of lows in her
strings so she can like pressure you
easily so yeah i feel like she's still
really strong but there was some hope
lab coat was nerfed just in time for the
dragon ball fighters world championship
which had the potential to prove that
the nerfs were enough and that a new
meta could breathe fresh life into the
game but not everyone was excited sonic
fox dropped out of the world
championship saying they felt
disrespected that the devs would make
such a huge change to the game just two
weeks before a major event after all
labcoat didn't get nerfed in a vacuum
her balance patch came with buffs and
nerfs to the entire cast it was
basically a new game and sonic fox
didn't feel like they had enough time to
properly prepare for the tournament plus
it's not like the game wasn't a good
place to begin with but miraculously
it seemed like the nerfs kind of worked
labcoat was only on seven teams in the
top 16 at the world championship clearly
she was still insane but nowhere near as
powerful as before though that might
have had more to do with the fact that
she had changed so much and pros didn't
want to risk picking her and messing up
with a new version of the character
there were still two players running lab
coat in top three so it's not like the
nerf kicked her out of top deer entirely
she just gets to hang out in s minus
here now that being said lab coat didn't
win the tournament wawa heroically ended
the lab coat meta by smashing every
single scientist in his path to win the
tournament that is done for nitro nitro
is trying to get in still he loses oh
that could be right there
just has to go for the simple combo he's
gonna build a ton of mirror he's got all
his characters he's going to go for
others
[Applause]
the best player on earth right now but
wawa's win heralded the beginning of the
fusion meta wawa went on to win evo just
after the world finals with gogeta blue
and vegito on his team and it's not like
lab coat went away completely top eight
still featured four lab coats at evo
though again character diversity is
definitely a lot better without her on
every team so what does the future look
like for fighters well despite months of
doom and gloom over labco21 and a couple
of resident sleepers in the chat for the
fusion meta
fighters is getting a new lease on life
uh we believe that dragon ball fighters
has been tuned to its finest so we do
not have future plans for any
new characters or a balance um
adjustments but here is the good news if
you have heard from her we have decided
to implement
robot netcode to drivable fighters
thank you
bandai namco's rollback announcement at
evo ensured the game will be playable
online for years to come and led to tons
of laps players casuals and pros to say
they're getting back into the game
unfortunately they also announced that
character and balance support for the
game has ended which means that the
patch that nerfed 21 is the last patch
the game will ever see potentially
trapping us in the fusion meta forever
lab coat is still strong probably the
best character in the game but
fortunately she is now beatable she's
not a nightmare there is a new season of
pro competition coming on the pipe and
hopefully the rollback netcode means
we'll be seeing a lot more people pick
up the game and maybe even find the
counterplay that can slowly push a lab
coat out of the meta we all hate this i
hate this my chat does not like watching
it you know it's not that fun to watch
lab coat 21 was single-handedly
responsible for nearly killing the game
but thankfully the developers listened
to the fans they took her down a peck
gave us the final update we all wanted
and maybe just maybe we can now bring
fighters back to life the lab coat
almost destroyed dragon ball fighters
but legends never die
they just rise again oh my god is blocky
that was so scary right there spin
behind in the two eight wow what waits
for it gets the hit i don't think this
is dead
that's dead that is done
took a while but the third character did
the job one nil on the french side
i just realized i have no water and my
throat is i'll be back in a second
[Music]
wow
all right here's like lubricate my
throat
[Music]